[Music]
hey Colonel Brian here with my pal Erin
Blair hello and that was awkward and
we're here with another clueless gamer
and this one is very exciting The
Witcher Wild Hunt
we are getting a sneak peak play yes
what can you tell us about The Witcher
Wild Hunt
do you want to hear the backstory
everything in my body says no but yes
let's hear the backstory all right so
you're a girl of Rivia you're a Witcher
and in this world rifts have opened up
where monsters have come in and so as a
result of that some people use the
resulting residual magic to remember
reading asking you deeply regretting it
continue
so basically guerrilla Rivia he's kind
of adopted this young girl named ciri
there's a girl named ciri yeah if she
the same one that tells you information
on the iPhone I don't think so
I was sure there's not a tie-in it's
very suspicious to me that The Witcher
befriends someone who happens to be the
voice of the iPhone and he doesn't with
his pet crow Google
there's the southern the Emperor Omer
Omer Omer Omer
he's emperor of nilfgaard is what you
need to know didn't you didn't just save
the Emperor nilfgaard did you oh yeah I
mean that's it's the proper title okay
I'm the emperor of nilfgaard guys stop
talking okay
you can't talk anymore okay anyway here
we go all right so this is a battle
going on between the southern supplement
I know this is a battle it was a bird
that just flew into someone's eye that's
fantastic
so that's yennefer who's our did you say
yennefer it's Jennifer no Jennifer
it's yennefer just say Jennifer their
name is Jennifer now we're a twitcher
keep banks of the Gwen oh my is that
sweet coming out of the tub and it's a
dude this game just outed me totally was
unfair why is he leaving who leaves when
a woman's sitting in a chair naked
what's happening make it freeze this is
you know that's Jennifer okay
she's gonna be naked I'll call her
whatever she wants to be called because
yennefer talked to the N afar
is there another verb there besides talk
to you nifer let's just talk
oh you want to hit a there yeah okay
let's talk see yeah I don't see we can
stand to wait a little longer
isn't there something you want to be
doing yes
not no sería ways isn't there something
you want to be doing
yes
not now see really isn't there something
the matter yes
not now
I've been in this situation before this
could take months I don't care what
realm you live in some things never
change
she's not in the mood do you think it's
possible that later on she'll have sex
with me
I mean maybe depending there are 36
different endings of this game so as
long as one of them is happy I think at
this point what's fueling me is that
it's clear that you can have sex with a
woman in this game right I want to do
whatever it takes to make that happen
that would be a new frontier for me I've
never done that okay
show me the letter from unified so when
looking for yennefer we're looking for
the lady who we saw naked before it does
smell of lilac and gooseberries while
again gooseberries look how far behind
you nifer are we well we were are only a
few feet behind her but then we sat and
talked for six days and now she's far
away in the land of zips our cool look
he's actually doing yard work
we cantle everything okay now we're
gonna skip ahead let's go to sex island
I wanted a lot of adventure okay okay so
where are we now we're on the skilling
Isles and one of the biggest things of
Witcher games is you hunt down monsters
yes hunting monsters seems to be a theme
let's walk around so we're gonna stalk
to the Oregon
oh hey hon come dusk of dawn attack
fishermen wielding just oars and
warriors alike you know what these
people like a nice long chat the cabbies
jackin of people I've ever met
do you know which way he went well it
puts me in mind of a tale how much time
have you got
yeah yeah I'll take a job I'll take the
job yes we're gonna go keep going people
bumping into each other sorry I'm not
quite big enough
Hey down towards the water we think the
drowners are down here you know what
drowners probably hang out near the
water
watch this check so now hold the left
trigger we're gonna use our Witcher
power
it says chicken sandwich oh yeah we've
well at least mr. Coombes you must go to
frac freak you must talk to the drowners
about the sea glug chicken said he has
mugs of beer
he's got nuts and berries oh he's got
apple juice yes is he a busy in
kindergarten time for my apple juice and
graham cracker there no time for a nap
and story where is his sex finder does
he have a sex finder I'm just gonna go
kill ya yeah no more [ __ ] Jason why
go for it go for it that's your line
kill them all was a time for talking
there's a time for fight oh whoops
it killed you to help me and you blew me
up now sorry about that
oh no I'm just a little on fire water
hag with our luck this is where we have
the sex with a water hey you know let's
get a look at her too in the light if
she's halfway decent I'm ready to go I
swear to God at this point the water hag
is looking good to me I'll just have one
or two of those beers okay water Hey oh
my god she needs a bra
I was
yes maybe we should just we get to skip
to you want to see something like naked
girls yes girls this is a sexy bathhouse
oh wow oh sorry there's two naked women
right here do I talk to them you could
try to talk to them I don't know if
anything will happen in my experience it
won't this is the kingdom of blue balls
oh I think we gotta talk to these gang
wonder just tried talking to about nine
different women got nowhere now we're in
the sausage Hut I'm just like inside the
bathhouse let's kill everybody well I'll
tell you one thing about our hero he
tied his towel very securely
I can't walk three steps without my
towel falling off now I'm just hitting
the alcove I hate how cold this pot is
so sexually frustrated you know what's
coming out of his hands his backed up
semen
sprayed it all over the place
I think that's great this is the most
erotic thing that's happened in this
game so I think there's a there's a good
part with yennefer yeah all right so now
we've been at a party with yennefer
we're going to steal this magical mask
which is gonna be a compass to help us
find ciri you're saying if I complete
this mission yes
yennefer will be so impressed yes I'm in
okay I'm in
all right go now have my incentive
Christian affirm talk to you nifer yes
this is eat Jesus is it what's that
growling speak his penis growling she's
happy penis growling Blacula shows up
this creature isn't something it's just
a burned pinata where's Jennifer I saved
her life
hello saved your life what's he doing
what's happening let's get this computer
this commit this could be it we must
know talking what when are you gonna
finally burn this sort of stuff in the
corn plate get out of here
[Music]
which er the Wild Hunt comes out May
19th and it's the best thing that ever
happened in my whole life sorry about
the crying at the end
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos